MILES BARR: Hello everyone! I am Miles Barr on the Google Play team.
Today, I will introduce you to some of the new tools we have developed.
These tools can help you grow your user base and interact with your users on Google Play.
Google Play lets you
Opportunity to reach 1 billion potential users
As a developer, the challenge is to get the right users.
Improve your app based on user feedback
And keep the app attractive to users for a long time
I will introduce some tools provided by Google Play.
These tools can help you easily meet these challenges
First, let’s first understand a great way to promote your brand.
That is the developer page
We recommend creating a unique page on Google Play.
To promote all of your apps
You can upload images from the developer page.
Briefly introduce your company
And pick an app for highlighting
This way, you can be on one page
Promote all your apps on Google Play
We have a quarter of our top partners already
Created a developer page
At the I/O conference, we announced that we will launch a new report.
Through this kind of report, you can better understand
User acquisition channels and
User's source
If you want to know how many users there are
Check your store listing
Will be able to find the answer through this report
You can track who has visited your store listing page
Learn how many percent of them are users
Installed your app
And eventually made an in-app purchase
This report will not only show your users’ access paths in the store.
And will also provide you with
Segmentation data by user acquisition channel
Now you will be able to understand
How much of the traffic comes directly from the Play Store
And how much is from other sources
Whether it's AdWords or Google search Urchin traffic monitor tag traffic
Or other third parties
You can see users before installing your app with a single click
Search keywords used in Google Search
Get the data you need
To optimize your store listing page
You may also be interested in tracking channel segments.
If you use the Urchin Traffic Monitor code in your Play Store link
You will be able to
Segment users from mobile websites or other partners
Now you understand the conversion rate between store listing visits and installs.
Let’s take a look
How to increase this conversion rate with Store Listing Experiments
Product Listing Experiment is
Another feature we launched at the Google I/O conference
With Store Listing Experiments, you can rely on specific data
Instead of relying on intuition to optimize your product listing page on Google Play.
Text and pictures
Product details page is
The place where the user decides whether or not to install your app
You can improve the performance of this page
And increase conversion rates
It can also help you improve over and over again
Most likely to resonate with the user
Marketing or product section
Developers often ask us
Conducting a store listing experiment
What is the best practice?
We think that everyone should mainly consider the following points
First, make assumptions and test
Test only one aspect at a time
After obtaining the results, it is repeated and improved.
You must make sure that the experiment is long enough
The results obtained in this way are statistically significant.
Please note the banner at the top of the page
Your experiment results will be displayed there
Remember, subtle adjustments may not work.
So let's experiment boldly.
Here is a good example
Rovio's store listing experiment for Angry Birds: Transformers
In the first experiment, they tried several different designs.
Found that the third design increased the installed capacity by 7%
Then they decided to make improvements over and over again
They tried to make the icons appear differently inclined
Then found the first slope
Increase conversion rate by 3%
Finally, they change the background color
To verify the experiment
As a result, they found that the original background color worked best.
So they continue to use this icon
This is what we got from Rovio.
Alpha/Beta testing on Google Play is very important
We are planning on Google Play now.
Try to release most of our upcoming games
Because we want to optimize and improve product page resources
We hope you also think this feature is helpful to you.
Try out apps and games for you on Google Play
Help
This way, when you fully publish apps and games
Must be able to achieve the desired results
we know
Getting users is a top priority for everyone.
In order to provide you with help in this regard
We’re launching a universal app campaign in the Google Play Developer Console.
For your convenience
This feature will be launched at the end of this year
Universal app campaigns streamline the campaign creation process
And provide you with one-stop service
Lets you target your app across all Google products and services
Whether the user is performing a search on Google Search
Using the Play Store or other related apps
Or there is no problem watching the video on YouTube.
Later in Bruce's speech, "Improve the installation of each channel as much as possible"
He will give you a detailed introduction to the universal app campaign.
After getting the target user
You will want to interact with them through ratings and reviews.
This is one of the most important parts of the Play Store.
Rating is the user to others
One of the most common ways to recommend your app
Ratings will also help you understand what users like and dislike about your app.
And how users feel about your app over time
Responding to user reviews is a great way
Allows you to build meaningful relationships with users
And tell them that you will listen to their feedback
To improve your product
If you didn’t respond to the user’s review
Then give it a try.
Most users will be at
Developers respond to them and update their reviews
We listened to your feedback
And added the features you need most.
Then, the rating page will show the score sheet.
You can easily track trends and ratings over a certain time period
You can search for specific group reviews
Free text search in all of your reviews
I hope that everyone likes the tools I introduced today.
These tools can help you promote your brand and developer page
Help you understand user acquisition channels
Optimize your store listings and help you grow your user base
And maintain good interaction with users
That way, you posted it on Google Play.
Apps and games will be a big success
Your feedback helped me and the Play team
Understand what challenges you face
So we can develop these features to simplify your work.
Thank you very much for your feedback.
We hope to hear more from you.
thank you all!
I am Miles Barr.